bonjour jérôme rivière merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france alors on l'a dit le beauvau
reprend aujourd'hui au ministère de
l'intérieur jean castex a émis des
propositions pour renforcer les peines a
commises à l'encontre des forces de
l'ordre peine de sûreté portées à 30 ans
au lieu de 22 rappel à la loi supprimés
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez je mens jour d'abord excusé moi
je pense que nous sommes encore une fois
dans un espace de communication vous le
rappeliez le bobo de la sécurité a
commencé il y à il ya un long moment il
est une mesure sur laquelle absolument
tout le monde s'accorde majorité
opposition syndicats de police c'est le
trou courte durée de la formation des
policiers en france nous avons une
formation qui est de 8 mois pour des
policiers en france avec par exemple
l'utilisation et l'entraînement au tir
une fois par an c'est très très
insuffisant comparé à la moyenne des
pays européens
dans ce discours où les policiers sont
pas en mesure de se défendre c'est ça
ils sont pas assez formés leurs armes
leur est un peu inquiétant puisqu'il ne
s'en servent qu'une fois par an avec 30
cartouches je crois simplement à pouvoir
utiliser
on est tous d'accord ce constat est fait
et en dépit de tout ça le gouvernement
n'a rien fait donc en fait vraiment du
débat des bobos de la sécurité on nous
annonce toute une série de mesures et
rien n'a été fait donc là je crains que
ce soit la même chose que face à la
pression de l'actualité où on voit que
maintenant tu es des policiers de
devient une activité quasi quotidiennes
pour les voyous où les policiers sont
perçus comme une bande rivale qu'il faut
éliminer le ministre vient nous parler
là en plus de mesures celles que vous
évoquiez celle de mathieu castex sont
des mesures qui concernent le garde des
sceaux et non pas le ministère de
l'intérieur
donc je crains qu'en fait le
gouvernement n'ait pas pris la mesure
des choses
la réalité c'est le risque de
séparatisme qui existent en france c'est
à dire 7 l'islamisme l'islam politique
qui est ton dos rond on pourra peut-être
parlé tout à l'heure avec eux des
manifestations interdites qui auront
lieu ce week-end et qui voit là et ses
manifestations 7,7 cette violence en
fait
augmente en raison de l'affaissement de
l'autorité de l'état
et c'est pas un aspect de communication
qui va malheureusement venir rattraper
ses quatre années de laisser-aller du
gouvernement des différents
gouvernements des manuels mais on va
parler de cette question de l'autorité
en français sur dix on va le voir disent
que c'est un problème voyez ce que ce
qu'a dit le sénateur retailleau
justement sur sûr c'est cette question
de la sécurité pour lui il faut d'abord
en connaître les causes écouter
policiers dans le coma dans la loire il
est temps de se préoccuper des causes
d'une situation de plus en plus
dégradées alors vous vous parliez de du
fait de pouvoir se défendre de pouvoir
manier les armes
quelles sont les causes selon vous
faut-il s'attaquer aux causes et quelles
sont elles évidemment qu'il faut
s'attaquer aux causes et c'est quand
même relativement malhonnête de la part
de bruno retailleau d'expliquer qu'on ne
les connais pas le président de la
république l'a lui-même expliqué dans
son dans son discours aux mureaux il
n'en a pas tiré les conséquences mais
les causes c'est ce séparatisme
islamistes qui existent en france qui
fait qu'un certain nombre de banlieue
aujourd'hui se considère comme étant des
zones avec un espace de droits
différents qui vivent du trafic de
drogue de crack spécifiquement et donc
c'est bien ça quand il faut dont il
d'autres il faut prendre la mesure
et tout ceci vient les chiffres sont là
pour le démontrer d'une immigration qui
n'a absolument pas été contrôlés
aujourd'hui vous avez à peu près 1 une
personne sur quatre a un détenu sur
quatre qui est étranger totalement
étrangers de très nombreuses autres en
double nationalité et donc cesser cause
la auxquels il faut s'attaquer
il faut massivement retiré la double
nationalité à ceux au délà quand ils ont
été condamnés
il faut expulser alors derrière on nous
répond mais vous savez les les pays
d'origine ne veulent pas les récupérer
ou ne veulent pas et il veut pas donner
de passer de deux passeports diplomates
de visas diplomatiques pardon de visas
consulaires excusez-moi aux étrangers
qu'on veut renvoyer chez eux alors
qu'ils ont commis un délit
la france a signé un accord
d'extradition avec l'algérie récemment
et au delà de ça si l'algérie ne leur et
ne ne veut pas respecter cet accord nous
avons l'aide au développement nous leur
donnons des milliards à ces pays chaque
année
on leur explique très simplement que
s'il refuse de reprendre les délinquants
qui ont été condamnés
et nous on supprime l'accès à cette aide
il faut une politique volontariste
on n'a pas aujourd'hui et vous avez
cette politique pro migratio nist qui
continue d'exister en europe en france
donc puisque emmanuel macron le meilleur
élève de l'union européenne et vous
aviez un sujet tout à l'heure qui
parlait de cette volonté de continuer à
ouvrir l'union européenne à l'albanie
notamment or on sait que l'albanie est
un des principaux couloirs d'immigration
vers vers l'union européenne
donc si vous voyez un double discours en
permanence de cette équipe macron
d'erding d'un côté ils viennent nous
dire là c'est terrible
il faut se préoccuper de la sécurité des
policiers et de l'autre côté ils ne font
rien pour éliminer la cause principale
qui sont des femmes
l'immigration massive qui continuent
d'arriver en vente en europe et en
france
la sécurité des citoyens français une
jeune fille de 17 ans poignardée par un
adolescent de 14 ans dans le val de
marne écouter d'abord sa mère et on en
parlera après aujourd'hui on a pris la
vie de ma fille et c'est un enfant qui
l'a tué
tout ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est
pourquoi ont-ils assassiné ma fille
le garçon est parti chercher un couteau
chez lui est redescendue et l'a
poignardé en plein coeur ma fille
n'était pas une délinquante
ma fille était une acharnée des études
elle souhaitait devenir ingénieur
comment est ce qu'on peut en arriver là
un enfant qui tue un autre enfant
finalement qu'elles sont quels sont les
moyens pour lutter contre ça selon vous
écoutez d'abord je pense à la douleur
atroce de la maman sait rien ne doit
d'être plus plus plus horrible que
d'avoir son son enfant assassiné de
cette façon là ce que je sais de 7,2
cette affaire c'est que ça a eu lieu je
crois dans le quartier hoche de cette de
cette ville qui par la même chose une un
quartier quasiment non droit encore une
fois la seule façon de pouvoir lutter
contre cette insécurité qui s'accroît
c'est de faire respecter l'état partout
sur tout le territoire de la république
aujourd'hui vous avez malheureusement
l'uniforme un problème de réseau sociaux
de
justement de montée de la violence à
cause de propos échangés cette règle oui
mais c'est parce que c'est pour ces
jeunes qui vivent dans un certain nombre
de ces quartiers
ils ont le sentiment que d'autres règles
s'appliquent il voit que sur des points
de crack là c'est la violence c'est le
des coups de fusil y compris contre des
policiers qui vont résoudre les choses
donc quand ils ont un différend il
considère que c'est possible de d'avoir
recours à l'extrême violence et à
l'assassinât
je pense que l'une des réponses c'est
d'augmenter le nombre de places en
centres éducatifs fermés pour les
mineurs pour répondre particulièrement à
ceux à ce sujet mais encore une fois
sans autorité de l'état avec l'autorité
parentale qui a a décru aussi nous
rencontrons aujourd'hui cette montée de
la violence qui n'est plus endiguer et
vous parliez de cette question de
l'autorité on a vue de rendre dans ce
sondage montré précédemment que neuf
français sur dix pensent que l'autorité
de l'état n'est plus assuré que c'est un
problème majeur autorités des parents
autorités policières mais autorités à
l'école également bien sûr vous avez eu
une volonté qui s'est manifestée qui
s'est accrue avec emmanuel macron qui
était de déconstruire la société
française donc la déconstruction est
passé par la déconstruction de l'école
aujourd'hui où les professeurs ont du
mal à se faire respecter
on ne lance n y plus des valeurs
essentielles
on se moque de la famille qui n'est plus
aujourd'hui à un lieu où doit se faire
l'éducation on les policiers les
militaires ne sont plus perçus comme
étant une autorité face à laquelle il
faut s'incliner et les respecter et ce
constat que font les français il est
partagé
souvenez vous par deux lettres fait part
dé des militaires des anciens militaires
et des militaires d'activé
il ya quelques jours par d'anciens
policiers je pense que c'est une réalité
qui s'impose à nous et il est temps de
restaurer cette autorité
une mesure simple vous savez il existe
aujourd'hui dans la loi la possibilité
de poursuivre loutre à genoux trash
c'est si quelqu'un insulte un policier
refuse de lui répondre
il peut être il peut être condamné pour
outrage à un an de prison et 15000 euros
damende pourquoi est ce que les
procureurs qui sont sous l'autorité
d'eric dupond-moretti
ne demandent pas systématiquement
l'application de ce texte de loi
ils ne font pas parce qu'en fait
emmanuel macron d'à côté d'un
assentiment de fermeté avec darmanin
mais de l'autre côté ne fait pas
respecter ses lois qui sont pourtant là
à notre disposition par son garde des
sceaux alors vous parlez des tribunes
des militaires et celles des policiers
ce week-end on va en regarder un extrait
justement les anciens policiers
appellent les élus à tout mettre en
oeuvre pour mettre fin à la situation
gravissime que traverse la france en
matière de sécurité et de tranquillité
publique
la peur doit changer de camp alors à
chaque fois ces tribunes ont été
condamnés par les hiérarchies
respectives pourtant elle présente un
constat que la population partage est ce
que vous pensez qu'on que c'est la bonne
façon finalement de d'appréhender ces
tribunes les condamner systématiquement
les présentant comme marginal
malheureusement pour nous collectivement
parce que c'est la réalité de l'état de
la france
non c'est très clairement une inquiétude
il relaye l'inquiétude des français
parce que ces militaires ces policiers
sont aussi des citoyens
ils ont sentiment très clair que rien
n'est fait et donc ils sonnent un peu si
je puis dire
le tocsin l'alarmant disons mais
réveillez-vous si rien n'est fait nous
allons basculer dans quelque chose de
bien plus grave qu'il sera encore plus
difficile d'arrêter mais il faut aussi
que le gouvernement sache donner
l'exemple vous savez lorsque vous avez
un ministre de la république une
secrétaires d'état en l'occurrence
madame grégoire qui vient sur la plateau
de télévision expliqué qu'il faut
abattre
marine le pen marine le pen et demi de
la république ce sont des propos qui
sont absolument insupportables qui
eux-mêmes supporter de la violence et
donc l'état doit être exemplaire or
l'état d' emmanuel macron ne l'est pas
du tout et la violence à tous niveaux
doit doit doit être stoppée on doit y
mettre un terme ça commence par
l'exemplarité des politiques qui vous
parlez d'abattre marine le pen ce sont
effectivement des propos qui ont été
prononcées ce week-end la sphère des
assistants des eurodéputés a fait la une
du journal du dimanche également le
front national
le rassemblement national de marine le
pen à et mis en place un système
organisé frauduleux c'est ce que dit un
rapport de police qu'en pensez vous on
va regarder d'abord la réaction de
marine le pen et et on vous demande
votre réaction juste après le journal du
dimanche
organe officiel du pouvoir n'a kronis tu
ressens la même sempiternelle à faire
des assistants parlementaires comme à
chaque élection
rien de neuf sous le soleil sauf
peut-être des bons sondages en vue très
vite organiste alexis poulain parler
d'une affaire fillon bis quel est votre
sentiment
on a un peu l'impression que alors que
les sondages sont effectivement
extrêmement mauvais pour emmanuel macron
extrêmement pauvre bon pour marine le
pen le le pouvoir essayer de faire
ressortir deux de ses cartons une
affaire qui date d'il ya plus de cinq
ans pourquoi est ce que la justice n'a
rien fait pendant cinq ans et puis c'est
si je puis dire le la pravda françaises
le jdd la pravda du dimanche qui vient
faire sauver la petite musique du
gouvernement en place tout ça est est un
petit peu triste parce que la justice on
le voit est très inactive et très
inefficace dans des sujets qui
concernent véritablement les français et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le temps de la
démocratie et des élections qui a lieu
il y avait 50 s'il y avait six avaient
des choses vraiment aller chercher y
avait cinq années pour les chercher que
ne sait que que n'a-t-elle fait la
justice donc non les français se
laisseront pas du thé par duper par ce
genre de ce genre de chose qui est
apparaît véritablement pour de la
manoeuvre
vous êtes député européen monsieur
rivière il ya eu des manifestations
interdites à paris en soutien aux
palestiniens
samedi qu'en pensez vous que pensez vous
également de du conseil de sécurité
incapable de trouver une position
commune sur cette question et l'europe
dans tout ça que peut-elle faire écouter
d'abord je pense que tout ce qui
concerne les affaires étrangères c'est
avant tout du ressort des états nations
et donc il n'est pas illogique que
l'europe ne trouve pas de position je
suis d'ailleurs très surpris que
monsieur morel continuent d'engager
l'union européenne dans un élargissement
qui n'est pas souhaitée pour lequel les
citoyens n'ont pas été interrogés pour
ce qui concerne le conflit israélo
palestinien
on souhaite tous bien sûr une résolution
avec deux états mais je veux quand même
appelé l'attention de ceux qui nous
écoutent sur le fait qu'en
vous avez aujourd'hui des politiques qui
sont qui poursuit une politique
islamique schiste et qui ne vont pas
manifestés pour la palestine mais qui
vont manifester contre israël et la
façon dont ils manifestent contre israël
c'est en manifestant contre l'état juif
et donc on passe très très vite de
l'islam de l'antisionisme c'est à dire
anti israël à de l'antisémitisme et la
montée des actes antisémites en france
qui est très inquiétante est directement
liée à 7,7 à ce discours qui aujourd'hui
porté par des politiques irresponsables
en france heureusement que monsieur
darmana interdit ces manifestations on
ne peut pas avoir sur le territoire
national des manifestations aux cris
mort aux juifs en france
arce a pas été le cas je le précise
samedi on va passer à un tout autre
sujet si vous le voulez bien c'est vous
avez eue samedi
vous avez eu samedi des manifestations
dans la france où vous aviez des mots
absolument abominable qui retenu contre
les juifs
on va on va on va parler de l'une d'un
tout autre sujet si vous voulez bien les
propos de françois bayrou qui préconise
plus de naissances et plus d'immigration
pour sauver le modèle français
je sais pas si vous avez vu cette alerte
de françois bayrou le haut commissaire
au plan l'a transmis à live fait ce week
end
est ce que c'est une bonne solution
selon vous bien sûr que non encore une
fois elle ça ressort de cette politique
immigrationniste les français c'est leur
première préoccupation
la france ne sait plus assimilé
n'assimile plus donc faire rentrer
encore plus
puis c'est la destruction finale de la
france donc monsieur bayrou fait
totalement fausse route qu'il fallait
une qu'il faille une natalité plus
importante c'est évident d urban un
position récemment en cela elle reprend
un certain nombre d'idées été
expérimenté en gris avec une aide les
familles qui ont deux puis trois enfants
on aide financière qui va croissante qui
permet le fait de faire face à la charge
financière que représente le coup
d'avoir une famille mais cette politique
immigrationniste d'abord on peut pas
continuer sans consulter les français
qui sont ces gens qui dans le secret de
leurs bureaux vont décider qu'on va oui
on va faire venir cette année à 1011
migrants les français ont le droit de
savoir et ont le droit de s'exprimer en
disant aujourd'hui non nous ne voulons
plus de migrants supplémentaires parce
que c'est me grande synthe
gros plus ces migrants soient plus pour
l'immense majorité d'entre eux d'origine
de pays qui sont civile de façon
civilisationnel totalement différent
nous ça n'est plus possible et c'est
très grave que monsieur bayrou continue
dans cette voie là merci beaucoup jérôme
rivière de nous avoir répondu ce matin
en direct sur rt france